well as you as you all see we have with
us the main teacher of this course and
we're all delighted mr. blade that
you're here with us what I propose that
we will do this session is I'll offer
some summary remarks about our previous
session and then introduce briefly the
session today and then mr. Blair is
going to give about 20 minutes or so
comments followed by Q&A then we'll take
a break and reconvene and then broaden
the conversation to involve readings but
as well as your experiences that you
bring to this course into the question
of what are the stakes where the
globalization and relationship between
globalization and faith today so let me
just offer a few summary first remarks
about our session first session we
affirmed of course the significance of
faith is a factor in many events faith
plays a significant role positive as
well as negative we also noted that it
virtually never is the sole factor and
suggested that all mana causal
explanations of complex events ought to
be suspect and therefore also all
monarch mana causal explanations in
terms of religious role but nonetheless
religion remains significant and
interesting thing also that came up in
our case study or presentation about
case study by Joan Kelsey is that he
underscored the significance of religion
but not just as motivating acts of
violence in this case and not simply
legitimizing at the bottom what are at
the bottom political or other goals but
in a sense providing a larger framework
in which to understand human life and as
such motivating actions which of course
with such courage of horse had such
charondas consequences that is there was
a idea of the human flourishing behind
bin Laden's
in London's initiative we know that also
ambivalence of concrete faiths various
kinds of ambivalences both from the
external perspective they appear both
positive and negative but also from
internal perspective they do so as well
and there's this long debate within
faiths themselves about what constitutes
the proper employment of faith proper
understanding of a faith proper action
in the world on the basis of faith and
now in our session too we asked the
question well how is this significant as
well as ambivalent phenomenon called
faith how is that phenomenon related to
globalization processes and more
specifically what is at stake when we
talk about faith in relationship to
globalization processes I will start and
I'll start by briefly defining our terms
and by sketching forms of impact the
faith can have on globalization and then
mr. Blair will take it from there and
talk more specifically to the heart of
our issue that is what is at stake when
we raise this question and examine it so
first terminology I don't intend here we
don't intend here to offer kind of
definitions that will give us essence of
faith or essence of globalization we
want to specify what we mean for the
purposes of our conversation by faith by
globalization by highlighting certain
features of these two phenomena and it's
also a flexible definition open to be
changed as we go along so what is
globalization globalization I think we
understand by the planetary process
which was historically driven primarily
by interest in and here I am drawing on
iron chandus work trade learning about
and spreading religion conquest and
adventure and probably in today's world
is most important driving force if it is
capitalism connected with trade but it's
a planetary process leading to and here
I'll be drawing on some of
readings that we had leading to a world
with high levels of interconnectivity in
which communication of goods and
services flow freely a world of second
interdependence that is planetary in
scope with only relatively few and
diminishing independent local localities
and the world in which space has
contracted in which the world itself has
become new locality and people are
increasingly D moored from a specific
territory some people talk about this
embedded cosmopolitanism as a feature of
globalization and then fourthly that
there is a widespread consciousness of
the world as a global whole those are
the four features of globalization now
what is faith faith by faith we don't
mean we've discussed this right quite a
bit and in our readings it's complicated
the discussions which will be now
reduced to relatively as simple saying
faith is not abstract religiosity of
which concrete faiths are specific
instantiations no such abstract
religiosity actually exists there may be
generic brands of products there are
many of those but there's no generic
believers they're all specific branded
so to speak believers faith faith come
in concrete shaped and believers believe
concrete faiths so what are some of the
features of those faiths great faith
traditions what are some of the features
of faith as we use it in this course
first they have at least so they have
that lists following features provide an
overarching interpretation of reality
with some claim to ultimately provide an
overarching interpretation of reality
with some claim to altima see now
situate second situate account of human
flourishing within that interpretation
of reality and then thirdly provide
guidance to people how they should live
and motivation to live
in this way now you'll notice probably
that something like Marxism or humanism
or even neoliberalism a function as
quasi religion given this definition
will keep in mind also a relatively
recent phenomenon when they speak about
religions and that is smorgasbord
religiosity which is neither religious
tradition nor some vague religiosity but
it is a concrete religious stance that
people take in contemporary world and
it's a corporate religious stance that
is kind of created by individuals to
satisfy their own religious needs and
content is kind of drawn in our coke
fashion from variety of sources and
often without being inserted in any
overarching perspective on life that too
I think is a consequence of
globalization on the shape which fate is
taking today so that's roughly what we
mean by faith faith should traditions
with these specified features and this
very relatively vague smorgasbord board
religiosity now faith in globalization
my next point is a kind of complex
relationship and it is a very complex
relationship one way to look at this
relationship is to ask what is the
impact but what are the impacts of
globalization processes on faith will
sketch that impact probably more in
greater detail in our next session and
today I am will be more concerned about
faiths engagement in globalization
processes I just want to note that the
influence goes both ways it's not just
from trade to globalization but in very
significant ways from globalization to
faith that the very shape of faith the
very modes of communication or faith are
all shaped by the situation in which we
find ourselves today in the globalized
world
so feints engagement with globalization
processes now obviously the first
question is the possibility of influence
on part of faiths of the globalization
processes and the assumption of the
course that such influence is possible
the fates are significant in the world
today
and that they're significant in an
ambivalent way as we noted in our last
session this is a contested assumption
but nonetheless I think it's it's a
reasonable one now let me indicate
briefly forms of impact our faith on
globalization processes obviously there
are such things as negative impacts
ambiguity of religion we emphasize them
dividends of religion and these are
often kind of identical maybe with that
kind of generally negative aspects of
faith I want to highlight to some people
think of faith as simply being
irrational right opposing important
scientific and technological
developments or opposing significant
social advances so there's a possible
negative impact as irrationality of
faith it's important note that from the
perspective of the believers themselves
they wouldn't describe that as
irrational they wouldn't see that as a
position between faith and reason
they would see that as from particular
perspective sketching a reasonable
understanding of how to orient oneself
in the world that too is part and parcel
of the ambiguity of faith second
negative aspect is violence generating
potential of faith creates strong and
exclusivist loyalties and legitimizes
struggle against others and this
negative impact of impact of faith is
magnified in an highly interdependent
world given that major disruptions in
one part have repercussions in just
about all other parts of the globe again
from the perspective of people of faith
faith that is deemed Island often is not
seen as simply engaging in blind
violence but rather sometimes is
perceived as being engaged in struggle
to live a way of live life deemed good
now we may not agree either with way how
people of faith some people have a
describe but it's the in rational
behavior we may not agree with an how
they describe their violent behavior but
it's important for us to understand
that they're not outs outbursts of
irrationality outbursts of violence that
they have internal reasons and only if
we understand those internal reasons
we'll be be able to engage in I think
creative and constructive ways with such
traditions now fates obviously have also
positive impact one to latch on to the
idea of of connection between faith and
violence fostering authentic
reconciliation we read in our texts
about militants for peace motivating
second motivating and energizing people
for more effective participation in
variety of settings there is a in the
Christian tradition in Jewish tradition
tradition of divine blessing where God
blesses wide varieties of efforts that's
- that that is - how people of faith
draw on their faith also helping people
in misfortune oppression or failure
there is in those traditions also kind
of deliverance tradition of faith faith
helps when things break down helping
people to live meaningful lives
notwithstanding failure oppression
misfortune or and energizing people to
help others but I think if the function
of faith in the context of globalization
or in general were to be reduced to this
blessing delivering and reconciling I
think that suspicion could arise that
faith is simply a clutch in
globalization processes in interface
with globalization faith is then made
possibly suspicions would be that faith
is made subservient to the ends of
globalization take the question of
blessing blessing if that's what faith
does simply blesses the endeavors well
faith can be deemed as maybe in negative
terms as a performance-enhancing drug
right or if faith is only about
deliverance right it would be kind of
religious band-aid or if faith is
involved just in reconciling processes
well it might be
as simply social lubricant right which
is in all these three ways faith would
be instrumentalized and background
assumption is that people afraid worried
for something that is ultimate to them
to being instrumentalized in what they
deem to be pinout penultimate where ends
faith then would be betrayed to retain
their own integrity as faiths faiths
must I think seek to shape globalization
processes in accordance with a vision of
human flourishing formulated within the
overarching vision of reality the shape
globalization processes in accordance
with a vision of human flourishing and
provide ultimate framework I think of
meaning within which globalization
processes make sense so for faith I
think that's probably true to say maybe
it's controversial and we can discuss it
for faiths globalization processes are
instrument and instrument they're not an
end right what does that mean for
globalization processes what does it
that mean for faith tradition traditions
as their interface with globalization
processes I think those are very
important issues for us to grapple and
to understand that as a inherent feature
of what faiths are about so just briefly
let me make a foray into what might be
at stake with globalization processes I
think in many ways it's not too much to
say that the future of our globalized
world is at stake a world in which
people of different cultures have been
brought into proximity with one another
a world in which people of different
cultures are increasingly dependent on
one another and increasingly see
themselves and citizens of one world and
maybe what is at stake can be expressed
in the following questions will all
citizens of that one world live in
genuine and just peace with one another
or will there be mired in irresolvable
conflicts too will globalization
processes be harnessed to help them to
better pursue authentic human
flourishing in the context of well-being
of all creation all will those processes
seduce them to pursue unreachable goal
of finding satisfaction in pursuit of
pleasure power or whatever that might be
I think those are some of the central
questions
formulated at least from the perspective
of the people of faith what is at stake
in engagement of faith with
globalization I shall end here and see
this place to mr. Blair thank you very
much
very loving I hope you don't mind if I
just begin by thanking Yael for giving
me the opportunity to to meet you and to
to take this course and thank all of you
for coming along and participating in it
because I want you to do a lot more for
me than the thing and listening to
Miroslav there reminded me of I was
never clever enough to be a professor
that's why they put me into politics now
what I'd like to try and do is explain
to you how I see this linkage between
faith and globalization and how I think
we can we can make our our work yield
some some good and important benefits
and as you probably know it's in part
linked to my um my foundation which is
about the whole area of interfaith and
how we get people of different religious
faiths to work and live together
I also this causes some surprise to
people particularly in my old calling in
in politics because I genuinely believe
that the issue to do with faith and
globalization religious belief and
global change
is the single most important and
determining issue of the 21st century
which is a big claim to make faith is
important because it motivates so many
people and because as we known as you
were exploring last week of its
potential to do harm but it's also
important because of its potential to do
good and I believe there is a way in
which faith can be the humanizing and
civilizing influence on the process of
globalization in another part of my life
I'm the the quartet which is
international community representative
for the Middle East peace process and
one of the interesting things for
someone of my religious background so
you go around the Holy Land and you see
all these very famous sights from the
from the Bible and I was in Jericho not
so long ago and my Palestinian guide who
is showing me around turned to me and
said at one point as he looked out over
the Jordan Valley and then Jerusalem in
the distance and so on and he said them
Moses Jesus Mohammed why do they all
have to come here
and it was his way of saying that in his
situation here he was in this quite
small geographical space which of course
is the source of such conflict and
difficulty at the moment knowing that he
and his children would have to live and
work together with their neighbors but
with this enormous difference cultural
and religious keeping them apart from
their neighbors so my point about this
really is very simple globalization and
defined as Miroslav is just so
excellently done globalization pushes
people together it pushes them together
economically and socially it produces
waves of migration the communication of
what is happening the world now crosses
frontiers with instant bees and
accessibility and the effect of this is
that globalization is something that is
seen as very modern but its impact is at
every point to push people into the same
space and with that of course comes
tremendous opportunities I mean if I
look around the class I mean you are a
representation of that people from many
many different parts of the world and
come to this great institution of
learning and that is really a normal
part of what we expect to happen now but
if you go back some generations that
would have been somewhat unusual so
globalization in my view by breaking
down some of the barriers and pushing
people together actually is a very
positive aspect to it it provides
opportunity for people who otherwise
wouldn't get opportunity it expands our
horizons our our ability to know more
about
world in which we live but it also of
course brings with it risks and dangers
and tensions because what happens when
traditional frontiers of community or
nation hood break down is that people
also feel under threat they feel under
threat about their own way of life their
own way of thinking if you study in my
country and of course in this country
too
the waves of migration and how they have
been assimilated that process of
assimilation has been tough and it's
been tough because those global forces
have changed do open up these new
horizons for people but sometimes people
don't want those horizons opened up they
find them threatening and disturbing but
the thing about globalization which is
why it a lot of the political debate
about it is often servant redundant is
that it's a fact it's not going to stop
it's only going to intensify and it's
also powerful and you only have to look
at what's happening to the financial
sector of the world economy at the
moment to realize that the moment
something happens here it's linked
translates right across the world and
that's not just because it's the United
States it's because of the integration
of the world economy now with faith that
a low global ization is seen as a modern
phenomenon faith is often seen as
something somewhat more old
old-fashioned and certainly in the
Western world sometimes people see faith
very much as something from the past not
in all parts of the West but in many
parts but it is also a fact and it is
also powerful when we look at the most
recent polling that's been undertaken in
this and we asked the question you know
is religion an important or very
important part of your life the figures
in Europe hover around the 30 percent
mark here in the US it's over 60 percent
in many parts of the world particularly
Islamic parts of the world
it's well over 90% and the fact is there
are billions of people in our world
today for whom faith matters I think it
matters hello it's one of the things
that I think we should explore during
the course of of of our endeavor I think
I would identify three aspects to faith
when we talk about it as an objective
force in our society in our world one is
that faith can become a means of
self-identity it it can become means as
saying that this defines my culture this
defines my political attitude it's it's
about identity I think a second aspect
of faith is that it's just part of my
tradition and that's a little different
from identity identity is something
living in present the tradition is
something that comes from the past but
people will say well I I grew up in a
certain type of society that was defined
by my faith that doesn't mean to say
that they personally necessarily are
people of faith but they would recognize
that that is the tradition from which
they come and then I think there's a
third way in which faith to to to people
Madison can be expressed and that is
faith as what I would call as a
spiritual awakening in other words faith
as it defines my values and beliefs not
in a cultural sense are much but in a
personal sense and so if you ask people
and to describe religion there are some
people who will describe it in terms of
identity there are some people who will
simply say well this is part of my
tradition but then there are other
people for whom this is the most
important thing in their life because
it's about how they live like their life
in what they do
to be a good way so it's it's it's
spiritual and I think when we examine
the impact of faith in those different
ways we can see as you saw last week the
good which is the Jubilee campaign and
and the bad which is faith leading to
extremism leading to violence leading to
the loss of innocent innocent life but
the one thing is for sure is that faith
in our world can be an immensely strong
justification for your action it can be
the motive act motivating and
galvanizing force behind what you do and
why you do it and the reason I say this
is so important for the 21st century the
20th century in my view is the century
of political ideology and a low as you
can see very well from what's going on
in your country at the moment we produce
great political turmoil and debate and
division and dissension over who should
be elected the President or who should
win an election in Britain nonetheless
actually the era of the great dominating
political ideology that was the answer
to everything
communism totalitarianism is over that's
not to say there aren't political
differences but they form they form up
in a quite different way in the 21st
century than the 20th with in Arab more
narrow parameters within a far larger
pool of consensus but religious ideology
has the possibility of supplanting that
political ideology for good or for bad
because when people ask well why is it
that you link faith to globalization it
is precisely because if globalization as
Miroslav was saying is a force that
pushes people together if religion
becomes a force that pulls people apart
if in other words it is not about your
spirituality but becomes a means of
identifying yourself in opposition in
exclusion to others then religion
becomes a force that can be immensely
destructive so what I summarized say to
people about globalization and about
politics today is that you know
distinctions between left and right
matter but actually as important as
anything else today's the distinction
between what I would call open versus
closed because globalization is a is an
opening up process the question is is
your attitude to that yes that's good
now how do we make it work or your
attitude to that is that's bad that's
taking away something of my identity of
something of what defines me and I want
to stop it now religion and those
circumstances therefore in religious
faith that can be a means either of
saying well let us open up to one
another and reach out across our
different faiths respecting our our own
faith in identity but being prepared to
reach out to the faith and identity of
others or it can be a means of saying
this is how I'm going to define myself
and in distinction to you because you're
coming into the space that I'm in
inhabiting is actually threatening my
religious belief and my faith so that is
one major aspect of the whole issue to
do with with faith and globalization is
it if globalization pushes people
together is religious faith a part of
making that work or is it does it become
part of pulling people apart but I
actually have a bigger ambition for for
what we want to do here which is also to
explore the possibility not that we
prevent faith from doing
harm but that we try and show and see
how faith can do good because thing
about globalization is that it is a fact
it is powerful and it does provide
opportunity but as again we can see it
is and can be highly impersonal it can
lead to a materialism that is actually
value free it can lead to injustice with
people who are left behind and I think
in the future it can do something else
it can lead to a competition for
resources particularly as China and
India industrialize errs it does and
there is a a developing of the world
economy increases in population pressure
on food as a commodity which you can see
already that process of globalization
which will create these types of
challenges the environment and climate
change will be another if it is value
free the danger is it is essentially a
competitive process decided by power so
those people that have the power and
will get the resources those people who
do not have the power will not and so
that very thing that globalization
should be which is an open up of
opportunity actually becomes a means of
creating a fundamental divide between
those who succeed in this world of
globalization and those who fail now the
question I would pose as this is it
possible for religious faith to be a
part not an exclusive part but a part of
providing a value system that brings
notions of equity and justice
fairness into this otherwise strong but
often impersonal process of
globalization can it in other words
develop and shape the value system of
globalization so what I'd like to do in
the in the course of our discussions
over the semester and a time to come
it's read trying to explore these types
of issues explore things like why don't
why do people still have such strong
religious faith why are people still
willing to come forward and stand up and
say that they have religious belief when
certainly at one time it was assumed
that as there was economic and political
and social development faith would be
relegated to an interesting part of our
history how do we remove the ignorance
that breeds the fear that breeds the
conflict in relation to faith I I think
for the Abrahamic faiths certainly but
more widely than that there's huge
ignorance I say this is someone of faith
about about other faiths the more I
learned the more I'm fascinated to learn
you know the more I see for example when
I study the Quran the more I see why we
call them the Abrahamic faiths and why
actually an understanding of Islam and
how it is developed is not merely
important for me to understand another
culture or another group of people but
actually is potentially a very enriching
source of knowledge for my own faith how
do we describe what our relationship
would be in the future with
civilizations Hindu or Buddhist
that are going to be immensely governed
by how those faiths came about the value
system underpinning them what the impact
of those phases been on the sociological
development of what a vast and growing
important parts of the world how do we
educate people about this how do we make
sure that the faith act in a way
together to deal with some of the the
critical issues in the world today one
of the things my foundation does is try
to get the face to act and pursuit of
the Millennium Development Goals for
example in the malaria campaign and then
how do we make sure that for this work
that we're engaged in we can start
identifying those things that maybe we
need to probe further in terms of
research or in terms of information what
are the case studies that would be
really interesting for us to look at in
terms of seeing the tensions between
faith and globalization and how they can
be improved and I hope finally also that
we are able to do something else which
is to to have an interfaith encounter in
other words sometimes you know when
people talk about interfaith dialogue
there are lots and lots I go to a lot of
interface sessions and there's an
immense amount of dialogue that a lot of
dialogue
and what would be nice is to get some
product at the end of it
you know and I think one of the things
that we can look at is what would be the
right way for the face to encounter each
other and to learn from each other and
finally to end where I where I began I
think when I'm out in the in the Middle
East and I see the good and the bad side
of faith and I see the conflict that it
is part of and I see the work that has
been done by people of faith to overcome
his historic divisions that of course
the death of so many people over the
years and I think if we were able to
find a way of reconciling people to each
other in that region what a symbol it
would be for peaceful coexistence for
the future so for me this is a very
practical thing I mean I am fascinated
in the theology of it actually and I'm
fascinated by the different doctrinal
aspects of it but most of all I'm
motivated by wanting to make the 21st
century work for people work for people
because as we open up we offer
opportunity to people and work for
people because in getting and in
spending we do not wait lay waste our
lives that in other words we have some
spiritual core to the lives that we lead
because I think in the end that is
really the only thing that makes life
properly fulfilling so these are these
are bold ambitions for our for our
course here at Yale but I am immensely
excited at the prospect of working with
you I'm sure I shall learn a lot from
you and I think that this is just the
beginning of something that will be
really in
important for the future and sometimes
as I've learned in my life out of the
very small things grow the very big
things thank you